marry me marry me
you look gorgeous
somebody's getting married
not a nerve in sight leading up to jlo's
long-awaited transformation into mrs
jennifer lynn affleck how you feeling
[Music]
well j.lo stayed true to her love don't
cost a thing pledge i am here at the
famous a little white wedding chapel
vegas venue where the couple worth an
estimated 550 million dollars said i do
with a 180 dollar tunnel of love
extravaganza
i am walking down the exact same aisle
that jennifer lopez took her steps on
saturday night just after midnight and
this venue's used to a-listers britney
spears got married here back in 2004 and
just a few years ago joe jonas and
sophie turner
and this
was my
wedding
changing area
why am i in the men's bathroom because
this is where ben affleck changed and
i'm pretty sure this is ben's hanger
still hanging here this is the wedding
they wanted everybody intimate
[Music]
e.t has obtained this exclusive photo
from inside moments after they eloped
jennifer wore a white lace off
off-the-shoulder gown from zuhair
murad's 2023 bridal collection earlier
in the evening she wore one of her own
dresses from quote an old movie
and check out jlo's post wedding glow
from bed the next morning showing off a
simple classic wedding band
jennifer's kids were in attendance here
is emmy in the chapel's cadillac no word
on if ben's three children were there ex
jennifer garner was enjoying the weekend
in lake tahoe according to our source
benefir wanted to elope in vegas because
quote they have so much fun together and
thought this would be a fun idea too
jennifer says it was quote the best
possible wedding we could have imagined
love is patient 20 years patient back in
2014 jennifer described ben as the one
that got away ben was your first
heartbreak it was my first kind of
heartbreak it was just one of those
things you know we were about to get
married it didn't work out and it was
just a tough one for me